thanks um
okay so i just want to start by
introducing myself uh i'm cindy i am uh
currently an assistant professor in
statistics at columbia before that i was
at yale where i got my phd and this is
what i look like without a mask on um
i this is my second semester at simon's
i was also here virtually
last fall for the program on probability
geometry and computation in high
dimensions
um so i just wanted to take the like 10
minutes today to give you sort of an
overview um about my research obviously
it's a short talk so i can't go into any
details but i'm here until december and
i sit upstairs and i'm always happy to
talk if you want to talk more so
kind of the short story is that my
research uses tools and ideas from a lot
of different fields like
information theory statistical physics
signal processing and applied
probability
in order to understand um
kind of modern high dimensional
statistical and inference statistical
inference and estimation problems
and also like a complex machine learning
task
um
so the thrust of my research isn't
answering questions like uh the
following so if we're given some like i
don't know hard stats problem
uh how much information or how much data
is necessary and sufficient to solve
that problem and then you know given
that data how do we most effectively use
it to gain insight on the problem at
hand and can we quantify the limitations
of that insight
or finally you know can we develop and
analyze
um
uh computationally efficient algorithms
to perform the sort of inference and
estimation
and so um with those questions in mind
uh i'm going to talk about kind of two
like overarching focuses uh of my my
research uh the first is on
understanding
uh fundamental limits of statistical uh
recovery
um and then you know if possible trying
to find computationally efficient
methods to perform at those limits so
this is kind of like
uh just core what like the program
uh i'm joining is about uh and then the
the second uh
part of my research is um
that i'm going to talk about today is on
establishing uh
sort of rigorous theoretical uh
performance guarantees for various
methods and procedures and high
dimensional uh statistics
okay so let's talk a little bit about
fundamental limits first so
uh information theorists have long
studied uh sort of establishing
fundamental limits on uh the transfer of
data in order to design you know
practical communication systems right
this is like core information theory
uh these days right it's it's obvious
that these sorts of ideas and
methodologies uh important in like sort
of any data-driven field where uh one
wishes to you know uh gain as much
insight from uh the data as possible so
for example you know statistics and
machine learning and so in these fields
you know
these data-driven fields it's now
important to establish computational and
information theoretic limits of problems
so along this line of work
i kind of i focus on two areas so uh one
is just kind of the like classic
information theory application
of like wireless communication so uh
in short what is the communications like
challenge right uh the idea is we want
to send some information over a noisy
channel and we want to send information
over the channel in a way that it's
reliable so you know uh the person at
the end of the channel understands what
you're saying uh we want to send the
information with data rates approaching
the channel capacity which is this
information theoretic limit and we want
to do this all in a computationally
efficient way so that you know our cell
phones like work in real time
right and so um
the kind of the the long story short of
how folks do this is uh
they um
build encoding and decoding schemes at
either end of the channel and so the
encoder will transmit a signal uh where
they've added some redundancy in order
to combat the noise in the channel and
then the decoder will take the output
and denoise it in some way
so um
my work specifically has looked at uh
sparse regression codes which is an
encoding scheme for various channel
models it kind of leverages the work
from the sparse signal recovery
community
in order to sort of challenge this uh in
order to tackle this uh communications
challenge
so the idea is that uh we encode our
information in a sparse vector
and then um you know uh when you send
that over uh the measurements of that
sparse vector over a channel the
decoding task um then becomes a high
dimensional linear regression problem
but one where the the number of you know
columns in your measurement matrix is
growing more quickly than the number of
rows
so um
in particular my my work has um
developed an approximate message passing
uh decoding scheme for sparse regression
codes
and um
the the basic idea is that you know if
we can add enough sort of structure to
the signal itself and uh this is
something we can do because it's a
designed problem right so i have control
over the signal and the measurements and
these things but if i can add enough
structure to the signal um relating to
the sparsity then i can sort of
rigorously show that amp will uh recover
the the true signal
um
in as few measurements as information
theoretically possible so uh in this you
know in the the language of
communications we are coding at the
channel capacity and so um i studied
this originally for just the standard
added of white now gaussian noise
channel which is like your
vanilla uh channel that you know
everybody learns in like chapter two of
the the information theory textbook um
but it's also used in more
uh complex channels that have kind of
modern applications like internet of
things and
and these sorts of um models i'll also
mention um related to this i have some
work
dealing with phase transitions with
changing sparsity and this is something
i'll talk
a little bit more about in the workshop
next week that sam mentioned earlier
um i just wanted to plug it real quick
now so uh what do i mean by changing
sparsity right um well i don't know for
i don't have to say this to uh uh people
in this room but i will right so um
often in high dimensional problems right
we we assume that the uh
underlying effective dimensionality of
you know the the the problem is much
smaller than the the natural
uh representation um
of of the dimensionality and and so uh
for this reason establishing sort of
information theoretic and computational
limits um in the context of sparsity is
something that researchers have spent a
lot of time doing but
usually um the the sparse models that um
we've studied are those where you know
if we have a sparse vector for example
um
the number of non-zeros
is a a small but like fixed proportion
of the length of the vector
and so um my work here studies uh a true
sparse limit where in fact if we think
about you know the the problem size
growing the sparsity is actually um
approaching uh zero
and so um this is kind of a fun uh
problem uh for me um so in particular
you know what what did i do well um i
was studying computational phase
transitions uh
for uh
rank one um matrix estimation and this
true
uh sparse uh setting and in particular
we were studying uh computational phase
transitions using approximate message
passing and um
i i kind of like this uh problem because
you know
um when we have this vanishing sparsity
we can't use the usual sort of
asymptotic analysis of the approximate
message passing algorithms we instead um
have to use like a finite sample
analysis which is something that i
studied um a lot during my uh phd
okay so just um to wrap up i wanted to
say a little bit about um my work that's
maybe uh less related to
um
this program but i still think is very
cool and um that's on the statistical
analysis of
high dimensional estimators
and so um
okay maybe i'll stay here for a second
um
okay so um what am i what am i i mean
here right well uh clearly like a a
major goal of modern statistics is to
understand um high dimensionality better
right so
uh you know we often find ourselves in
situations where we like to estimate an
unknown signal or maybe an unknown
function and we imagine a model where
you know the number of parameters in the
problem is growing as quickly or more
quickly than the sample size
so um in in those settings right um
a usual way to to estimate that unknown
signal or or
density is um
to minimize some sort of empirical
distance measure between you know uh the
data and then uh the best estimator and
some sort of constraining set so for
example you might constrain your vector
to be sparse or um your function to be
smooth
and it turns out that uh iterative
algorithms um have proven to be very
successful in sort of solving these
constrained optimization problems and
giving us you know uh these these sorts
of um
these high-dimensional estimators
and so uh with these ideas in mind my
research has um studied uh
the the theoretical analysis of
approximate message passing algorithms
um to study these sorts of constrained
optimization problems
um and also uh the use of approximate
message passing
uh
as a tool to give us sort of exact
asymptotic characterizations of these
statistical estimators
so um just a quick word on amp so
uh why why are we talking about amp here
well one of the reasons that um amp is
so powerful in these situations
is that um
through a recursion referred to as state
evolution
uh
the the sort of amp analysis allows for
exact characterization of the
algorithm's asymptotic performance at
every iteration and it turns out that
these sorts of guarantees through the
state evolution can then be used to
establish
exact like high dimensional
characterizations of various statistical
estimators and this is done by
essentially constructing a suitable amp
iteration for your problem one that
solves the the optimization you're
interested in um
and then you can kind of like push the
amp state evolution guarantees uh from
the algorithm on to uh the estimator
itself
and so um
with this in mind my work has studied
you know mathematical analysis of um the
amp algorithms
usually motivated by uh the use of amp
and specific problems where the sort of
standard analysis um
no longer uh
was applicable um and then i've also
studied the the using amp
as a tool to give us um some analysis of
the high dimensional performance of
various estimators in particular um
i've studied l1 penalization a lot um
through uh the lasso and also a
generalization of the lasso called um
the sorted l1 penalty or slope
um okay so that's all uh i was gonna say
today uh i sit upstairs please um come
talk to me if you have any questions
thanks cindy so we have a break before
so save everybody back here of course
yeah